der Journalist Paolo beritzi von der
italienischen Tageszeitung la Republica
muss seit dreieinhalb Jahren unter
Polizeischutz leben rund um die Uhr weil
er Morddrohungen bekommt von Neo
faschistischen Gruppen über die er
schreibt
das sage ich jetzt hier mal eben so aber
allein das ist ja mitten in Europa
bereits ein unfassbarer Zustand guten
Abend Herr berberitzi
Grazie guten Abend und vielen Dank für
die Einladung was erwarten sie denn
jetzt nach dem Wahlsieg der extremen
Rechten in Italien für ihren Alltag
nun wenn die Signale so sind wie wir sie
heute vernommen haben
dann ist es so dass viele von denen die
mich täglich
bedrohen
sich jetzt beschützt fühlen und bestärkt
fühlen auf eine gewisse Weise also sie
haben schon damit begonnen daraus die
Konsequenzen zu ziehen und sie haben
schon
Dinge gesagt wie also hau ab oder bring
dich um oder du wirst sowieso hier
vertrieben solche Reaktionen gab es
bereits und das überrascht mich in
keinster Weise nur ist es so dass wenn
die Führung in Italien einfach so
darüber hinweggeht und einen
Journalisten nicht schützt der so
bedroht wird von den militanten Personen
dann ist das sehr schlecht denn sie sind
ja sehr stark vernetzt und sie sind
nicht zart beseitet sie bedrohen mich
und irgendwann wird es vielleicht auch
weitergehen aber ich mache mit meiner
Arbeit weiter ich mache einfach immer
weiter und versuche den Angriffen und
Attacken so gut wie möglich
entgegenzutreten
jetzt war das eine demokratische Wahl
aber an deren Ende muss man fragen wie
gefährlich sind die Wahlgewinner für die
Demokratie was meinen Sie
also ich bin hier sehr klar ich glaube
nicht dass mit Georgia Meloni und den
fratellit Italia an der Regierung direkt
der Faschismus zurückkehrt das glaube
ich nicht jedenfalls nicht so wie wir
ihn aus der Geschichte kennen
die wirkliche Gefahr besteht darin dass
unsere Demokratie geschwächt wird sie
wird angegriffen und das steht schon im
Grunde im Wahlprogramm der fratellit
Italia wo es heißt dass man die
Verfassung möglicherweise verändern will
die Verfassung unserer Republik das ist
ja doch die Grundlage unserer Demokratie
und da wollen sie dran gehen also die
wirkliche Gefahr für unsere Demokratie
besteht darin dass man so ganz leise in
etwas anderes abgeleitet eine Situation
abgeleitet wo wir keine wirkliche
Demokratie mehr haben sondern ein
autoritäres Regime wir haben das schon
in Umgang mit Urban gesehen und
beobachtet und
nee es steht ihm ja sehr positiv
gegenüber das ist das wahre Risiko
haben sie gesagt es besteht die Gefahr
dass Italien langsam abgeleitet was
glauben Sie was ihre Landsleute dazu
sagen ist ihnen das egal setzen sie
gerade zu da drauf also vor allem die
Wähler natürlich von Georgia Meloni und
ihren fratelli d'Italia oder haben sie
das einfach im Moment immer noch nicht
als als Bedrohung tatsächlich vor sich
welches
wurde sehr stark unterschätzt und zwar
jahrelang es wurde auch banalisiert das
Phänomen wurde nicht so erkannt wie es
wirklich ist ich glaube dass die Wähler
der fratelli d'Italia sich in zwei
verschiedene Kategorien unterteilen
lassen es gibt einen Teil der wieder
schafft er sich ja moderat ist und dann
gibt es einen Teil der Wählerschaft der
sicherlich
das braucht dass diese Symbole
existieren dieses Logans die werden
wirklich gesucht auch von dieser
Wählerschaft und ein roter Faden wird
gesucht etwas an dem man sich
orientieren kann und das geht in die
Richtung des Faschismus also wenn man
auch Italien
nicht so in der Gefahr sieht dass wir
auch keinen wirklichen Neo Faschismus
erwarten können so gehen wir doch in die
Richtung und die Partei mit der wir es
zu tun haben steht auf jeden Fall in der
Tradition in der Faschisten die fratelli
d'Italia ist Faschisten die sind da
tatsächlich drin und wir können im
Grunde sagen dass seit 45 bis heute ist
die Regierung ist die so rechts ist wie
keine andere Regierung in der
Zwischenzeit ist war es ist ganz klar
dass die Faschisten im Grunde doch
irgendwo Anteil an der Region Italiens
haben das ist eine Tatsache
sie als Touristen da kennen wir Italien
als Traumland als Sehnsuchtsland wie
würden Sie uns denn ihr Land beschreiben
und vor allem seinen aktuellen Zustand
bei dem ja viele Italienerinnen
Italiener offensichtlich gar nicht mehr
zur Wahl gehen und dann sehr viele den
extremen rechten Rand wählen
in wenigen Tagen jetzt zum hundertsten
Mal der Marsch auf Rom am 20 Oktober das
war der Anfangspunkt des früheren
Faschismus und Italien
hat heute
festgestellt und gemerkt das ist eine
Regierung haben wird mit Faschisten und
dieser Marsch auf Rom der Anfang des
Faschismus das ist sicherlich ein
bedeutendes Datum das uns nochmal zum
Nachdenken bringen sollte mit was wir es
hier zu tun haben und
manches was wir da sehen hat wenig zu
tun mit Demokratie und es geht sich an
eine andere Richtung das wird langsam
passieren aber es wird doch passieren
aber wenn wir wirklich wach geworden
sind dann können wir vielleicht noch was
tun
von La Republica herberitzi hat sich
dank für das Gespräch heute abend Graz